do you spend time with your family good
because a man who doesn't spend time
with his family can never be a real man
you can do anything but never go against
the family
strength of a family like the strength
of an army lies in its loyalty to each
other
keep your friends close but your enemies
closer
I work my whole life I don't apologize
to take care of my family I don't
apologize that's my life
[Music]
she's very beautiful to you she's
beautiful for me there's only my wife
and son
[Music]
a man who is not a father to his
children can never be a real man
a friend should always underestimate
your virtues and an enemy overestimate
your faults
falling in love is great but being in
love is a disaster
any man can turn traitor
some Honorable Men spend their whole
lives preparing for a supreme Act of
treachery
[Music]
we are all Honorable Men here we do not
have to give each other assurances as if
we were lawyers
[Music]
the lawyer with the briefcase can steal
more money than the man with the gun
behind every successful Fortune there is
a crime the
[Music]
many young men started down a false path
through their true destiny time and
Fortune usually set them a right
foreign
never let anyone know what you are
thinking
power wears out those who do not have it
[Music]
when they come they come at what you
love
[Music]
my whole life trying not to be careless
women and children can afford to be
careless men cannot
you
men in general sooner forget the loss of
their matrimony than the death of their
father
be careful it's dangerous to be an
honest man
like many businessmen of Genius he
learned that free competition was
wasteful Monopoly efficient
you lived like a fool and you have come
to a Fool's end
none of us here wants to see our
children following our footsteps it's
too hard a life
[Music]
your love is also your weak point
the richest man is the one with the most
powerful friends
even the strongest man needs friends
[Music]
understand friendship more than women do
as I am a reasonable man I'm willing to
do whatever is necessary to find a
peaceful solution to these problems
[Music]
don't raise your voice improve your
argument
[Music]
I have learned more in the streets than
in any classroom
good health is the most important thing
more than success more than money more
than power
each man has his own destiny
time erodes gratitude more quickly than
it does Beauty
[Music]
I respect those who tell me the truth no
matter how hard it is
[Music]
in this world there comes a time when
the most humble of men if he keeps his
eyes open can take his revenge on the
most powerful of men
friendship Is Everything friendship is
more than Talent it is more than the
government it is almost the equal of
family
I raised my daughter in the American
fashion I gave her freedom but I taught
her never to dishonor her family
Italians have a little joke that the
world is so hard a man must have two
fathers to look after him and that's why
they have Godfathers
my father is no different than any man
with power
like a president or a senator
do not count on the Gratitude of deeds
done for people in the past you must
make them grateful for things you would
do for them in the future
[Music]
your enemies always get strong on what
you leave behind
foreign
best served cold
never hate your enemies it affects your
judgment
[Music]
[Music]